an alarming escalation of the corona
virus pandemic after a period of decline
we've hit another daily record with
nearly 40,000 reported new cases now
that's the second day in a row that
we've hit a record high forcing some
reopening plans to pause we've also had
the most deaths yesterday in more than
seven weeks California Florida and Texas
have all had major spikes with between
28 and around 34,000 new cases in the
last week we are in all three states
this morning and we begin with Janet
shamlian in Houston Texas where
officials warn hospitals may soon be
overwhelmed as they were in New York
earlier this year Janet just how packed
are the hospitals there Anthony good
morning the Texas Medical Center is the
largest cluster of hospitals in the
world late last night it reported its
ICU beds were 100% full the Texas
governor has now issued an executive
order banning elective procedures in
four of the state's largest counties
that order coming after record-high
COBIT hospitalizations each of the last
14 days this is Houston's Methodist
Hospital we're almost a third of the
patients in the ICU have Kovac the
remaining have other illnesses with
hospitals at capacity
they'll have to turn regular beds into
critical care ones we want to reassure
the public that this pandemic is not
eclipsing our capabilities video from
Methodist shows the busy scene doctors
and nurses wrapped in personal
protective equipment are on the front
lines of the fight against Kovan how
long can you keep going at this pace if
this trajectory remains for the next
10-15 days no matter which hospital
system would be stretched to the limit
some experts say reopening may need to
be rolled back entirely so it's pretty
clear that these measures by themselves
dr. Peter Hotez is a Dean at the Baylor
College of Medicine
he says the latest models show Houston
reaching four thousand daily cases of
corona virus by the July 4th weekend
it's already a tragedy for Ron barbosa's
family in north
taxes after get-together a few weeks ago
18 relatives now have coronavirus his
parents and sister who has cancer are in
the hospital I'm hearing it for so many
young people now that are like I could
get the flu before the the virus kills
me well guess what it happened to my
family you're gonna carry it and you're
gonna give it to somebody and when it
hits that person that needs chemo that's
trying to stay alive now you're trying
to kill them and here in Houston Harris
County has now banned all gatherings of
more than 10 people to try to slow the
spread of this virus but it is proving
to be very challenging
Tony fat you alright Jana thank you very
much